country superstar luke combs pulled out
all the stops for one very special fan
over the weekend during his stadium show
in ohio as part of the buckeye country
superfast yeah grab the tissues for this
one luke flew out 17 year old addison
conley and her family for the trip of a
lifetime addison is battling leukemia
and got to hang out with luke backstage
with addy's mom calling it the best
night of their lives oh i love that and
luke's generosity didn't stop there addy
even got the chance to join luke on
stage for an emotional performance of
his ballad better together take a look
and we will see you next time bye
well i want to introduce you to somebody
this is my friend addie that i met today
and uh
addy's going through some health things
at the moment and i came across her on
social media
i had been tagged in a few things
and her
uh
biggest wish was to come out
and see a show
and i want to
[Music]
give her
the experience of what it really feels
like to be up here in front of 60 000
people playing a song
so addy this one goes out to you
your favorite song
one of my favorite songs this is better
together all right
let's do it some things just go better
together
and probably always with like a cup of
coffee
and the sunrise sunday drives in time to
care
and if i'm being honest you're first in
my last name
what you saying
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you